no pueden quedar impunes el gobierno de
Perú intenta cuidar su imagen
internacional
mientras que crecen las denuncias del
exceso en el uso de la fuerza por parte
de la policía contra los manifestantes y
se militariza regiones del sur la
presidenta Dina boluarte sostiene una
postura conciliadora ante organismos
internacionales este miércoles boluarte
pidió la ayuda de países amigos en
videoconferencia ante la Organización de
Estados Americanos oea para adelantar
las elecciones en Perú y lograr una
salida pacífica y prometió Investigar la
denuncias sin embargo el congreso
peruano rechazó un dictamen en diciembre
el año pasado que estipulaba la
celebración de elecciones presidenciales
en diciembre de 2023 con un apoyo casi
unánime los congresistas acordaron
postergar los comicios hasta abril de
esto aumentó la atención social en las
calles los manifestantes exigen la
renuncia de boluarte el cierre del
Congreso y el adelanto de elecciones
luego de que el expresidente Pedro
Castillo fuera destituido y detenido por
el delito de rebelión la señora de una
vez tiene que entender
sin posibilidad de tregua a corto plazo
tanto los manifestantes como el gobierno
mantienen su postura Dina boluarte
atribuyó la reciente violencia en Perú a
algunos organizadores de las protestas
este legítimo derecho de protesta no
obstante no puede significar que se
permita socavar las bases de la
institucionalidad democrática y de la
convivencia pacífica entre peruanos en
consecuencia con boluarte las
autoridades de la región de puno una de
las zonas más afectadas por la violencia
extendieron 10 días más el toque de